um so for all of those people who are
stressed or feeling stressed about that
about being divorced like it's a it's
congratulations congratulations all
right I want to point something out what
are we gonna rank Emily one to ten I
would put her as an eight or higher look
at Earl's a nice chick today I'm gonna
I'm gonna put her in a nine in her feet
a nine
now you know you know she's an eight you
know I mean that that woman she's
clearly aged well I mean who knows tick
tock's got all the filters so you never
know what the chicks look like but you
know let's just say an eight right she
is hot and the difference is you know
she's telling these women she's selling
them what I call selling the dream
um you know divorced women don't tend to
have good outcomes they tend to get
divorced again or not married again and
if they do get married they tend to get
divorced yeah so these women they they
it tends to go downhill for them